[Music]
google kubernetes engine or gke's
cluster auto scaler feature enables
clusters to automatically resize the
number of nodes in a node pool without
manual intervention based on your
workload demands
the auto scaler triggers the node scale
up events when there are unscheduleable
parts and node scale down events when
there are under utilized nodes the auto
scaler prints any scaling decisions made
to increase or decrease the size of the
node pool any errors that occurred
during the scaling process etc as events
or entries in cloud logging the cluster
autoscaler logs can help in
investigating any issues with auto
scaling
in this video we will look at how to
view the cluster auto scalar logs
including how to troubleshoot and
resolve one of the events observed in
the log
first we will learn how to view cluster
auto scaler logs
in the google cloud console go to the
logs explorer page
from the resources drop-down list select
kubernetes cluster
then select the location and name of
your cluster
from the log name drop-down list select
container.googleapis.com
cluster autoscaler visibility
from the time range drop down list
select a time range in our cluster
we'll view the logs for the last har
cluster auto scaler events may also show
up as notifications in the google cloud
console user interface
notifications can help you monitor
scaling events in the cluster and act on
them if needed
oh there's indeed a notification in our
cluster which states that the cluster
autoscaler can't scale up nodes because
node auto provisioning is disabled the
details section below the notification
may have some additional information
about the event
if you click on logs it will take you to
the logs explorer page directly
now let us look at the no scale up event
which is one of the most common event
types
a no scale up event is locked if the
auto scaler cannot scale the cluster any
further this happens if there are
unschedulable parts in the cluster and
the auto scaler cannot scale the cluster
up to accommodate them
you can refer to the fields like reason
and
nap failure reason to understand why
scale-up failed
the reason field provides information on
why the cluster autoscaler is prevented
from scaling up the nodes
for our cluster the reason field has the
value max node group size reached this
indicates that the cluster autoscaler
could not scale up because the maximum
node size for the node pool has been
reached hence no more nodes can be added
the nap failure reason field provides
information on what prevented the
cluster auto scaler from provisioning
additional node pools
for our cluster this field is populated
with value no scale up nap disabled
which means that node auto provisioning
did not provision any new node groups
because node auto provisioning is
disabled
to solve this problem we can either
increase the max size limit for auto
scaling for the node pool or enable node
auto provisioning for the cluster
check out the documentation to see more
about viewing cluster autoscaler events
and understanding the different reasons
the same
[Music]